So now we set the stage for discussing the spin and the exokernel approaches
to achieving extensibility of the operating system without losing out on
protection or performance. Both these approaches
start with two premises. The first premise,
is that micro-kernel based design compromises
on performance due to frequent border crossings.
And the second premise is that, monolithic design does not lend itself to
extensibility. Because of the starting premises of spin and exokernal.
Both these approaches have certain commonality in what they strive to
do, although the path taken by these two approaches are very different.